[Music]
the city wasn't good for us we had been
dreaming about a place like this for a
while now this would be the baby's room
the house it's been listed for a while
why hasn't anyone bought it
there was an incident we uh we don't
want to know
we do
there was a suicide double homicide
i suppose you're out
no you know i don't mind a little
haunting
we'll take it
kind of perfect right
[Music]
this door won't open yeah
i thought they just had a daughter
there were two
i'm sorry i didn't mean to scare you
but i guess you folks aren't from around
here
uh who who are you probably the closest
thing you have to a neighbor
what happened to the toy truck
i don't know how things just keep
disappearing
you stopped seeking care when you move
the move was supposed to fix things
[Music]
i found the windows in her room nailed
shut
so no one would find out what he was up
to
you okay
you look like her
what happened to the boy he wasn't
killed
he lives in the house next door
it's this house
i don't feel like i'm alone here
[Applause]
the wardrobe
there's a reason
it is where it is
[Music]
what
you